un point tox comme ça chaque soir avec
anthony s'alléger bonsoir anthony
bonsoir la suède attendre demain
mercredi les résultats des législatives
qui ont eu lieu dimanche la droite
alliée au parti anti-immigration
pourrait l'emporter alors certains
comptes twitter francophones ont affiché
leur soutien à l'extrême droite en
partageant et en décontextualisant une
vidéo a effectivement vidéo que l'on va
découvrir ensemble que voit-on sur cette
vidéo et bien vous allez le voir on voit
un rassemblement des femmes vêtues de
voile noir qui pour certaines ont des
enfants en poussette on va voir aussi un
petit peu plus loin des hommes qui
brandissaient des drapeaux avec des mots
inscrits en arabe on les voit ici ces
vidéos selon les différentes
publications vous le voyez elles ont
cumulé les vues au total plus de 300
milles vue essentiellement je vous le
disais des comptes twitter francophones
plutôt
sympathique de l'esc l'extrême droite en
témoigne par exemple celui de damien
rieu de reconquête alors que nous disent
justement les publications qui partagent
cette cette vidéo est bien qu'il s'agit
d'une manifestation d'un rassemblement
de
d'islamistes pardon mobiliser contre
l'extrême droite l'extrême droite je
vous le rappelle qui est arrivé presque
en tête en tout cas selon des résultats
partiels puisque demain devrait être
publié les résultats définitifs jimmie
akesson que l'on voit là le leader pour
être donc bien devenir la deuxième force
politique après la droite a dans le pays
alors que montre réellement ces images
anthony et bien pour le comprendre il
faut opérer trois étapes finalement la
première c'est la géolocalisation on va
le faire ensemble pourquoi parce que on
va revenir sur une capture d'écran de la
vidéo virale est un détail va nous
mettre la puce à l'oreille c'est ce
grand détail que l'on voit ici c'est
cette sculpture pourquoi parce que grâce
à la géolocalisation on va pouvoir
montrer que cette photo a bien été
tournées que cette vidéo pardon a bien
été tournées en suède on retrouve les
éléments en question ici on est en fait
donc à malmö plus précisément malmö
c'est ici au sud de la suède stockholm
est là et là on est sur la place de
malmö devant la galerie d'art voilà pour
la première étape la seconde elle va se
concentrer sur différentes détails de la
vidéo en l'occurrence retour là encore
sur une capture d'écran de la vidéo
virale l'élément en question il est ici
un drapeau ce drapeau c'est celui de
l'imam hussein que l'on voit ici l'imam
hussein qui est une figure de l'islam
chiite et pour cause c'est le petit-fils
du prophète mahomet mahomet pardon mort
en martyr à la bataille de kerbala en
680 après jésus-christ cet événement et
fondateur de l'islam chiite et plus
précisément du mouvement chiite est ce
qui nous intéresse c'est que la
commémoration de sa mort elle entraîne
40 jours de deuil une fois que cette
période est terminée vous avez ce qu'on
appelle la fête d'arbaïn est justement
lorsque vous cherchez sur youtube les
mots harbin et malmö vous retrouver
différentes images des processions
religieuses qui ont pu avoir lieu les
années précédentes à malmö cette ville
suédoise et sur youtube anthony on
retrouve justement la procession de
cette année oui plus précisément
l'événement a eu lieu le 10 septembre
vendredi dernier donc et lorsque l'on
cherche donc les mots que je vous disais
vous retrouver par exemple cet événement
qui a été enregistré donc sur youtube en
live le live commence en fait juste
après la vidéo virale mais vous voyez
vous reconnaissez très bien le point de
rassemblement la même classe il ya aussi
plusieurs détails qui vont venir nous
confirmer qu'il s'agit bien du même
moment en l'occurrence on va prendre
celui ci c'est une capture d'écran là
encore de la vidéo virale on va se
concentrer sur l'homme en question
barbe blanche petit petit brassard blanc
est également un brunch blanche et bien
cet homme vous le retrouvez ici à gauche
l'image virale à droite l'image du live
sur youtube l'ubs ça c'est pour le
premier élément on va prendre un
deuxième élément ici et ici alors j'ai
inversé par rapport à tout à l'heure à
droite vous avez la vidéo virale vous
noterez ici des panneaux numériques pour
celui-ci et des affiches que vous
retrouvez également ici cette fois sur
la vidéo du live de la procession de
cette année donc s'il y a bien eu un
rassemblement à cette année et peut plus
précisément ces derniers jours sur la
place de malmö en suède ce n'était pas
un rassemblement politique contre
l'extrême droite mais tout simplement
une procession religieuse merci beaucoup
anthony pour ce décryptage dans le
contexte donc de cette chronique info
intox rester avec nous
la suite de paris direct en quelle rue
dans quelques minutes